الكمبيوتر التليفون المحمول وغير ذلك من
الاجهزه الالكترونيه التي لم نعد نستخدمها
بشكل خطوره بالغه على البيئه وعلى صحه
الانسان اذا ما تم التخلص منها بشكل
عشوائي من هنا تاتي اهميه فكره اعاده
التدوير الالكتروني بشكل صحيح
[موسيقى]
مع طرح اجهزه حديثه كل يوم تزداد رغبتنا
في التخلص من القديم حتى وصل حجم النفايات
الالكترونيه في مصر الى نحو 90000 طن من
سنويا
مخاطر الحاجات دي على البيع ان هي بعد كده
بتروح في ال ااا لو التخلص تم التخلص من
عن طريق قطاع غير رسمي بتروح في الاخر في
ال- اا في التربه بترجع لنا في الاخر في
الاكل في الشرب في الميه في حياتنا ودي
بتاثر بعد كده على الصحه ممكن بقدرات سبب
سرطان او امراض دم او امراض ثانيه مزمنه
من هنا جاءت فكره اي تدوير اول تطبيق لجمع
النفايات الالكترونيه من المستخدمين
بمقابل المادي او عينيه وارسالها للمصانع
المختصه لاعاده تدويرها بشكل امن
[موسيقى]
ايه تدوير انت بنعمل قيمه للمخلف اللي في
المنزل في البيت اللي عند المواطن عادي
احنا جعلنا في مقابل
للمخلف ده انت مجرد متصوره بتحطه على
التطبيق بيطلع لك اقرب مكان تضربه فيه او
تكلم فيه المكلف بتاعك ده بسهوله انا
هاقول لحضرتك الاول
وما بها من رصاص ومواد اخرى تمثل خطوره
على البيئه
الذهب طبعا الذهب والفضه بيتباع بسهوله
قوي يا بلاد هنا بنطلع النحاس منها بطريقه
امنه
البورده بقى
بتتفك بتروح المرحله اللي هي هناك ديت
بتتكسر
[موسيقى]
التخلص من البيانات الخاصه على هذه
الاجهزه وهو يعتبر اكثر ما يقلقوا صاحبا
الجهاز
الالكترونيه مع التطور السريع في مجال
التكنولوجيا ما يتطلب زياده الوعي بكيفيه
التخلص منها بل والاستفاده منها ايضا سمر
باشات لصباح العربيه من القاهره